le plan de relance premier point de
négociation entre joe biden et mme et
républicains le président américain a
reçu ce mardi à la maison blanche
plusieurs sénateurs de l'opposition à
l'ordre du jour le plan de sauvetage de
l'économie contesté par ces derniers les
sénateurs républicains propose de
diviser par trois le budget prévu dans
ce plan de sauvetage s'élevant
initialement à plus de 1,9 milliard de
dollars
un premier test pour joe biden pour en
savoir plus sur sa volonté de gouverner
dans un esprit de discussion c'était un
très bon échange de points de vue
je ne dirais pas que nous nous sommes
accordés sur un plan de ce soir personne
ne s'attendait à ça lors d'une réunion
de deux heures
nous avons convenu de poursuivre et de
discuter davantage au niveau des
collaborateurs entre nous et avec le
président et la vice-présidente sur la
manière dont nous pouvons continuer à
travailler ensemble sur cette question
très importante
autre priorité de joe biden
l'immigration sur ce point l'actuel
président américain souhaite prendre une
direction drastiquement opposé à son
prédécesseur par le biais d'un décret
joe biden a demandé à ses collaborateurs
de faciliter le processus de
naturalisation
le président des états unis souhaitent
également lever les freins à
l'immigration mise en place par donald
trump
au total neuf millions de migrants sont
éligibles à la nationalité américaine
le président biden crois que les
immigrants sont essentiels à notre
identité nationale est indispensable à
nos aspirations pour l'avenir
l'administration précédente a mis en
place des centaines des politiques qui
vont à l'encontre de notre histoire et
sable caractère de l'amérique comme
terre d'opportunités ouverte et
accueillante pour tous ceux qui viennent
ici à la recherche de protection et
d'opportunités à l'international le
président américain a mis les bouchées
doubles lors de ses premiers jours à la
maison blanche entre la signature de la
prolongation du traité russo américain
new start ou encore la suspension des
ventes d'armes à l'arabie saoudite et
des chasseurs f-35 aux émirats arabes
unis
les relations diplomatiques avec l'iran
sont actuellement en cours de discussion
avec en point d'orgue
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
enfin le coup d'état en birmanie
constitue le premier grand test pour joe
biden l'actuel président américain
pourrait profiter de cette occasion pour
vouloir remettre les états unis au
premier plan de la scène internationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça a été
évoqué dans les commentaires du
président comme vous le savez nous avons
levé les sanctions les états unis
devrais je dire enlever les sanctions
sur la birmanie au cours de la dernière
décennie sur la base des progrès
réalisés vers la démocratie
l'annulation de ces progrès nécessitera
une révision immédiate de nos lois et
autorité en matière de sanction suivie
d'une action appropriée
outre les dossiers économiques
migratoires et diplomatique joe biden
doit également faire face à la crise
sanitaire
pendant sa campagne il avait annoncé
vouloir vacciner 100 millions
d'américains lors des cent premiers
jours de son mandat
un défi de taille alors que les
etats-unis ont déjà recensé plus de 440
3000 morts depuis le début de la
pandémie